Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Welcome to The Rest Is History. Yesterday we were talking paganism, horned gods, mother goddesses, Wicca and the world of 20th century witchcraft. And today we'll be digging back a bit further into that history with the same guest, Professor Ronald Hutton from the University of Bristol, who says nobody should be considered a world expert,
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。如果您想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社团，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。欢迎收听《历史的余烬》。昨天我们探讨了异教、有角神、大地女神、威卡教以及20世纪巫术的世界。今天，我们将邀请同一位嘉宾——来自布里斯托尔大学的罗纳德·赫顿（Ronald Hutton）教授，继续深入探讨这段历史。他认为没有人应该被视为什么世界级专家，
but since it's our podcast, we can decide. And I think if we want to crown him the world expert, we will, and we have. So, Ronald, what can we say with any certainty about pagan religion? Can we talk with certainty about it? I just removed my crown again. I'm stubborn on this. The answer is it depends which pagan religion you're discussing. Anything prehistoric is
但既然这是我们的播客，我们说了算。我想，如果我们想给他加冕为世界级专家，我们完全可以，而且我们也已经这么做了。所以，罗纳德，关于异教信仰，我们究竟能确定些什么？我们能确定地谈论它吗？我又把王冠摘下来了。我在这方面很固执。答案是，这取决于你讨论的是哪一种异教。任何史前的事物都
anybody's guess because we only have material remains and they are mute. So you can reconstruct all sorts of religious scenarios, but also social scenarios and political scenarios from the same evidence. And also for Northern Europe, it's extremely threadbare because we don't have any written sources before Christianity. We have quite a lot for certain places like Scandinavia and Ireland, which is Christian but talking about pagan times, but we don't know how reliable it is. But we have a huge amount of evidence for the great classical civilizations in Mediterranean, where you actually have written sources with which you can interpret the material remains, and lots of art of different kinds representing rituals and deities. So we actually can say things with absolute certainty. in time and in kind of mental distance, that even though we have, let's say, all this Greek art
只能靠猜，因为我们只有物质遗存，而它们是不会说话的。所以你可以从同样的证据中重建各种各样的宗教场景，甚至社会场景和政治场景。对于北欧来说，情况也极其单薄，因为我们在基督教出现之前没有任何文字资料。对于某些地方，比如斯堪的纳维亚和爱尔兰，我们有相当多的资料——它们虽然是基督教地区，但记录的是异教时期的事，只是我们不知道这些资料有多大程度的可靠性。不过，对于地中海的伟大古典文明，我们有大量的证据，在那里你实际上拥有可以用来解释物质遗存的文字资料，以及大量不同种类、表现仪式和神祇的艺术品。所以，在时间和精神距离上，我们确实可以极其确定地说出一些事情。尽管我们有，比方说，所有这些希腊艺术
and all this fantastic sort of Greek literature, it's very, very hard for us to, I mean, we can know what people were doing, but we don't necessarily know what they meant by it or what was going on in their imagination while they were doing it. We can actually say this, I think, if only because they argued over it. Greeks would argue over anything. And so actually the Romans, but more as intellectuals. You get an entire book by the most long-winded and pompous intellectual of Julius Caesar's Rome,
以及所有这些了不起的希腊文学，但对我们来说，要理解它们仍然非常非常难。我的意思是，我们可以知道人们在做什么，但不一定知道他们这样做是什么意思，或者他们在做这些事时脑子里在想什么。实际上，我想我们可以这样说，如果仅仅因为他们为此争论过的话。希腊人会对任何事情争论不休。罗马人其实也是如此，但更偏向于知识分子式的争论。你可以读到尤利乌斯·凯撒时期的罗马最啰嗦、最自负的知识分子写的一整本书，
who's Cicero, on the nature of the gods. That's a bit harsh. I think that's absolutely... I've been waiting all this podcast for somebody. I find he's so vain and pompous, isn't he, Ronald? I'm afraid that's true. I mean, also, he writes an appallingly difficult Latin, and any schoolboy who's trying to translate Cicero just yearns for somebody else. But anyway, he writes a book about the nature of
也就是西塞罗写的《论神性》。这话说得有点刻薄。我觉得这绝对……我整个播客一直在等有人这么说。我觉得他太虚荣、太自负了，对吧，罗纳德？恐怕确实如此。我的意思是，他写的拉丁文难得令人发指，任何试图翻译西塞罗的中学生都渴望能换个人来翻。不过无论如何，他写了一本关于
the gods in which he discusses every theory that's being aired about the divine and his time. So you can actually look at the arguments. So you don't just get people doing things without explaining them, which is the case in some other civilizations. You actually get people trying to explain what they're doing and wondering why and talking about it. So I think you do have windows into their souls. But Ronald, a very, very simple question here from Dick of Axe, who asks, what is paganism? And if I could just kind of broaden that out. I mean, the idea of a pagan is a Christian one, isn't it? Yes, it is. But it's a very handy term. It isn't needed until Christian times,
神性的书，在书中他讨论了当时流传的关于神的所有理论。所以你实际上可以去审视这些论点。你不仅仅看到人们在做一些没有解释的事情——在某些其他文明中确实如此，你实际上能看到人们试图解释他们在做什么，思考原因并对此进行讨论。所以我觉得你确实能看到他们内心的窗口。不过，罗纳德，来自阿克斯的迪克这里有一个非常非常简单的问题，他问：“什么是异教？”如果我能稍微扩展一下这个问题的话。我的意思是，异教徒这个概念是一个基督教概念，对吧？是的，确实如此。但这却是一个非常趁手的词。在基督教时期之前，这个词并不需要存在，
because everybody was a pagan. But once you've got Christians, paganism does become a separate category of religion. It's nice to have a term for it. And what's more, the term is not pejorative. It's actually quite specific. We've only really got to the bottom of what it meant in the 1990s. For a long time, it was thought it meant a country dweller, a bumpkin. Then we realised that couldn't be right because it was coined when most urban people were still pagan. And then it was thought it meant a civilian, somebody not enrolled in the army of Jesus, which again has a slight aspersion to it. But now we realize it just means people who carry on the religion of the Pargus, which is the local Roman unit of
因为所有人都是异教徒。但一旦有了基督徒，异教就成了一个独立的宗教类别。有个词来称呼它挺好的。而且更重要的是，这个词并不是贬义的。它其实相当具体。直到20世纪90年代，我们才真正搞清楚它原本的意思。很长一段时间里，人们认为它指的是乡下人、土包子。后来我们意识到这不可能对，因为这个词创造时，大多数城市居民仍然是异教徒。再后来，人们认为它指的是平民，即没有加入耶稣军队的人，这同样带有一点贬义。但现在我们意识到，它仅仅指那些延续“帕古斯”（Pargus，罗马地方行政单位）宗教的人，
government. In other words, those who follow the old religions, the rooted religions, the local religions, instead of the brash, new, missionary, aggressive religion of Christianity that transcends lands and boundaries. And as a definition of the pre-Christian religions of Europe and the Near East as an umbrella term, it works perfectly. Okay, so we need this word because basically christianity is is emerging in late antiquity towards the end of the roman empire in the west um endures in byzantium and there's a very obvious question which i guess is anyone who's been to india for instance where gods that were worshipped centuries thousands of years ago are still
换句话说，就是那些遵循古老宗教、扎根于本土的宗教、地方性宗教的人，而不是基督教那种超越土地和边界的、气势汹汹的新兴传教性宗教。作为对欧洲和近东前基督教宗教的统称，这个定义完美契合。好吧，所以我们需要这个词，因为基本上基督教在西罗马帝国走向晚期古物时正在兴起，并在拜占庭延续。这里有一个显而易见的问题，我想任何去过印度的人都会有同感——在印度，几个世纪、几千年甚至崇拜至今的神祇，到现在依然
worshipped to this day. It's absolutely focused. And this is from, inevitably, Stefan Jensen, who, honestly, he just won't stop asking questions, but they're very good questions. So keep them coming, Stefan. Why did Christianity totally eradicate pre-Christian religion in Europe? Why aren't there any pagan remnant communities left in Europe after the Middle Ages? So I guess that's the big question. Why was, you know, in yesterday's episode, you're basically saying that there are no
受到崇拜。这是一个绝对核心的问题。这个问题来自不可避免的斯特凡·詹森（Stefan Jensen）。老实说，他就是停不下来不提问题，但这些都是非常好的问题。所以斯特凡，请继续提问。为什么基督教在欧洲彻底根除了前基督教时期的宗教？为什么中世纪后欧洲没有留下任何异教的残余社群？所以我想这是个大问题。为什么，你知道的，在昨天的节目中，你基本上是在说，没有任何
kind of pagan continuities that run through the Middle Ages into modernity, perhaps from the kind of, we'll come to the one tradition that might. But why is it so successful? What happens? You can answer that question most easily by panning back to look at the world, because Christianity is not unique in world religion. It's one of a very unusual but extremely powerful subset of religions, which we call world religions. In other words, religions of salvation, religions of the general message for humanity,
贯穿中世纪到现代的异教延续性，可能除了那种……我们会谈到那种可能存在的传统。但为什么它会如此成功？发生了什么？你可以通过放眼世界来最轻松地回答这个问题，因为基督教在世界宗教中并不是独一无二的。它是少数几个非常不寻常但极其强大的宗教子集之一，我们称之为世界宗教。换句话说，它们是救赎之宗教，是面向全人类的普遍讯息，
carried by people who think humanity will be improved everywhere by converting to their religion. Islam's another, but also branches of Buddhism, Confucianism. And these religions are very effective steamrollers. Everywhere where they go, where they reach rooted indigenous immemorial religion, they tend to wipe it out. And they wipe it out in two ways. One is by converting the local leaders by offering them an enhanced role and also a place in the afterlife. And so that way you behead the traditional religions, which were carried on by the local political and social leaders. And that's exactly what happens in Europe. You go for the kings or the emperors
由坚信全人类都可以通过皈依其宗教而在各处得到提升的人们所传播。伊斯兰教是另一个例子，佛教的某些分支、儒教也是如此。这些宗教是非常高效的压路机。无论它们走到哪里，当它们接触到扎根于本土、自古以来的宗教时，它们往往会将其抹去。它们通过两种方式将其抹去。一种是通过赋予地方领袖更高的地位以及在来世的一席之地来使其皈依。通过这种方式，你斩首了由地方政治和社会领袖维系的传统宗教。这正是欧洲发生的事情。你针对的是国王或皇帝，
and the rest follow. But also there's a psychological thing that there's simply nothing inherent in indigenous religion to stand up to a religion of missionary work and conversion there's no tradition of answering these things because you've never had to and so they tend to go over because they have nothing inherent in them that tells them they can resist that habituituates them, which is why later when indigenous religions are revived, which happens all over the world, it's not just a British or European thing, they tend to be a lot tougher and take on some of the attitudes and the techniques of world religions. And that's just... Right. So yesterday you were talking about this gospel, the gospel of witchcraft, and you talked about conversion. So there are kind of echoes there of what Christian
其余的人就会效仿。但这里还有一个心理层面的因素，那就是本土宗教中根本没有什么东西能够抵御传教和皈依的宗教。那里没有回应这些挑战的传统，因为你以前从未经历过这些。所以他们往往会选择归顺，因为他们身上没有什么内在的东西告诉他们可以抵抗，也没有让他们习惯这种抵抗。这就是为什么后来当本土宗教复兴时（这在全世界各地都会发生，不仅仅是英国或欧洲的现象），它们往往会变得强硬得多，并吸收世界宗教的一些态度和技巧。这就是……没错。所以在昨天的节目中，你谈到了这个福音，巫术的福音，你谈到了皈依。所以这其中其实有着基督教
missionaries were doing. Yes, that's right. Paganism never has scriptures, because pagans are not religions of the book. They're religions of ritual and contact with the natural world. So the term gospel or scripture applied to paganism is an imposition on it from an alien language. It's interesting that at the present day, although sometimes particular writers market their books, mostly to Americans, with titles like the Bible of the Witches or whatever. The sacred writings of modern pagans are books of ritual. There's no theology there at all. There are no laws telling humans how they behave in relation to the divine, as opposed to each other. So it remains a different concept.
传教士所做之事的某种回响。是的，没。异教从来没有经文，因为异教徒不是经典宗教。他们是注重仪式和与自然世界接触的宗教。因此，将“福音”或“经文”这两个词套用到异教身上，是用一种外来语言对它的强加。有趣的是，在今天，尽管有时特定的作家会向美国人推销他们的书，书名诸如《女巫圣经》之类，但现代异教徒的神圣著作其实是仪式书。那里根本没有神学。没有告诉人类如何在面对神明时行事的法律，也没有规定人与人之间关系的法律。所以它依然是一个不同的概念。
But that is a continuity though, isn't it? I mean, is that a deliberate attempt to preserve the spirit of original paganism? It may just be a natural thing to do, because if you're going to be pagan, you have to model yourself on ancient paganism to some extent. And there are just certain things that are bred into it, like not having Gospels or Scriptures, but also having feminism, environmentalism and personal choice. Yeah. Just before we go to a break, there are two kind of traditions that people have argued did survive from pre-Christian times, pre-Islamic times, into the modern. One of them is raised by Joshua D. Terry, who asked, what should we make of pagan iconography in early and medieval Christianity, such as the green man? Does it reflect a covert resistance or intentional co-option? And I suppose there's the the sheila and the gigs aren't
但这确实是一种延续性，不是吗？我的意思是，这是对原初异教精神的一种刻意尝试去保存吗？这可能只是一件很自然的事情，因为如果你想成为一个异教徒，你多多少少必须以古代异教为榜样。而且有些东西是融入其中的，比如没有福音书或经文，但也包含着女性主义、环保主义和个人选择。嗯。在我们进入中场休息之前，人们一直争论有两类传统确实从前基督教时期、前伊斯兰时期延续到了现代。其中一个由约书亚·D·泰瑞（Joshua D. Terry）提出，他问：我们该如何看待早期和中世纪基督教中的异教图像，比如绿人（Green Man）？这反映了一种隐蔽的抵抗还是刻意的吸收？我想还有
there which are um ladies not being polite which you pick what you get in churches and so on you're being very coy about i am this is a family podcast um well let let let let me put it in a plainer way but one that still shouldn't be offensive. Green men are enigmatic faces gushing foliage often from the nostrils and mouth or framed in foliage. And Shielner gigs are much rarer, but they're still spread over Western Europe. And they are unclothed women squatting facing the observer in a way that emphasizes their sexuality. And these are indeed at first sight very weird figures to find in medieval churches. Unfortunately, although I think there are, as I said yesterday, continuities between ancient and modern paganism, these church figures don't seem to be those anymore,
谢拉基格（Sheila na Gig），对吧？也就是那些……不太文雅的女性形象，你在教堂等地方能看到。你对这个话题表现得很拘谨啊。我是啊，这是一档合家欢播客……好吧，让我把它说得更通俗一点，但同时又不会显得具有冒犯性。绿人是那些神秘的面孔，枝叶从它们的鼻孔和嘴巴里喷涌而出，或者被枝叶所环绕。而谢拉基格则要罕见得多，但它们依然分布在整个西欧。它们是赤裸的女性，以一种强调其性特征的方式下蹲着面向观察者。这些确实是初看之下在的中世纪教堂里会觉得非常怪异的形象。不幸的是，尽管正如我昨天所说，古代异教与现代异教之间存在延续性，但这些教堂里的形象似乎不再属于这种情况了，
largely because of research in the 1980s and 1990s. The idea that they were pagan images of churches is a product of the 1930s. It wasn't floated by experts in medieval art or indeed in the Middle Ages at all. It was produced by folklorists looking at churches now. Margaret Murray was one of them, wasn looking at churches now. Margaret Murray was one of them, wasn't it? Margaret Murray, she was the one who proposed the Shielaner gigs.
这主要归功于20世纪80至90年代的研究。认为它们是教堂里的异教图像这种观点，是20世纪30年代的产物。它并不是由中世纪艺术专家或中世纪的人提出的。它是当时研究教堂的民俗学家提出来的。玛格丽特·默里（Margaret Murray）就是其中之一，对吧？玛格丽特·默里，正是她提出了谢拉基格的说法。
And it was an aristocrat called Lady Raglan, who in her one significant publication coined the term the green man taken from a pub sign for the foliate heads. We now have the research done. The green man comes from India. He is originally a pagan motif from India, from Hinduism, but becomes a decorative one, but then travels along this vast information superhighway called the Arab Empire, which stretches from the Indus Valley all the way to the Pyrenees. And it arrives in Spain, which is still largely Islamic, gets into Christian monasteries there, and spreads as a decoration for monks' manuscripts across 10th century Western Europe, and then gets into churches. And as far as we can see, yeah?
而提出“绿人”这个词（取自酒吧招牌上的绿叶头像）的是一位名叫拉格兰夫人（Lady Raglan）的贵族女性，这是她唯一有影响力的出版物。现在我们有了相关研究。绿人其实源自印度。他最初是来自印度的异教母题，源于印度教，但后来变成了一种装饰图案，然后通过被称为阿拉伯帝国的这条巨大“信息高速公路”传播开来——该帝国从印度河流域一直延伸到比利牛斯山脉。它抵达了当时大部分地区仍属伊斯兰教的西班牙，进入了当地的基督教修道院，作为10世纪西欧修士手稿的装饰传播开来，随后又进入了教堂。就我们目前所能看到的而言，对吧？
Yeah, it's purely decorative it has no yeah as far as we can see it actually has no meaning it's simply a decoration that's i love that it's attractive and you can put it it has different moods you it's especially suited to being put on on various bits of churches like tim parney and bosses roof bosses. It's different with the Shielner gig. She's part of a package, but the name is Irish, incidentally, but she doesn't start in Ireland. You just find her most commonly there. She starts in France in the 11th century as part of the package of movements for a decorative tradition we call Romanesque. And they're in pilgrimage churches along major pilgrim highways, and they teach moral lessons.
对，它纯粹是装饰性的，它没有……就我们所能看到的而言，它其实没有任何意义，它只是一种装饰。我喜欢这一点，它很有吸引力，你可以把它放在……它有不同的情绪，它特别适合被放在教堂的各个部分，比如横梁和屋顶的雕花饰。谢拉基格则有所不同。她是整个传统体系的一部分（顺便说一句，这个名字是爱尔兰语，但她并非发源于爱尔兰，你只是最常在那里发现她）。她于11世纪起源于法国，是被称为“罗马式”的装饰艺术传统运动的一部分。它们出现在主要朝圣路线上的朝圣教堂里，并传授着道德教训。
And so the moral lesson of the Schielner gig is sex is repulsive. Don't think about it. Think of higher things, which is why the ladies concerned are pretty well always grotesque. They're really unappealing. These are not. They're designed to put you off rather than entice you that's it but uh and it's quite a big but i said that they're more common in ireland
所以，谢拉基格传授的道德教训就是：性是令人反感的。不要去想它。去想更高尚的事物。这就是为什么相关的女性形象几乎总是那么怪诞。它们真的毫无吸引力。这些设计是为了让你感到厌恶而不是引诱你，就是这样。但是——这是一个很大的“转折”——正如我所说，它们在爱尔兰比在其他地方更常见，
now than an eastern survival than elsewhere and in ireland they do seem to have a slightly different significance which could be plugging into native paganism, because they're found on secular buildings a lot more than they are elsewhere, and also in places where the human eye can't see them. And there does seem to be a recorded Irish folk tradition that a woman exposing herself would frighten off evil or a curse from recording. Right, so it's kind of like the evil eye. Yeah, that's right. It's an antidote to the evil eye. Okay, so the possibility there... Sorry, Dominic, I was interrupting you.
在爱尔兰，它们似乎确实具有稍微不同的意义，这可能与本土异教有关，因为它们在世俗建筑上比在其他地方更常见，而且也常常出现在人眼无法看到的隐蔽地方。爱尔兰确实有据可查的民间传统：女性暴露自己可以吓退邪灵或解除魔咒。没错，所以这有点像避邪眼（evil eye）。是的，没错。它是避邪眼的解药。好吧，所以这种可能性……抱歉，多米尼克，我打断你了。
I was about to say, before we go to a break, though, that surely raises a much bigger question, which is how much does... So in the sort of folk imagination, if you like, in the popular imagination, there is now a sort of... Among people who've not read up on all all this there is this sort of vague sense oh christianity must have incorporated lots of elements of pre-christian religions and they survive and and there are lots of pagan bits
我正要说，在我们进入中场休息之前，这难道不会引发一个更大的问题吗？也就是……在某种程度上，在民间想象中，在普通人的想象中，现在有一种……在那些没有研读过所有这些资料的人中间，存在着这样一种模糊的感觉：哦，基督教一定吸收了大量前基督教时期的宗教元素，它们存活了下来，基督教日历中有很多异教成分之类的东西。人们对万圣节往往也有这种看法，不是吗？这是真的吗？中世纪的基督教包含了很多异教成分吗？它在基督教化时是否接管并吸收了这些？人们经常问起圣诞木柴（yule log）和诸如此类的事情，这其中有什么真实性吗？是的，是的，以及是的。我本该早点谈到这个，但我知道自己刚才有点滔滔不绝……无论如何，世界宗教成功的方式之一，不仅在于它们铲除了旧的信仰或旧的传统，
of of the christian calendar and all this sort of stuff i mean halloween people often think this about halloween don't they is that true did medieval christianity have lots of pagan had it taken over and incorporated when people often ask about the yule log and all these kinds of things is there any truth in that yes yes and yes uh i should have covered this earlier but i knew i was going on a bit anyway uh one of the ways in which world religions succeed is not just they stamp out the old faiths or the old traditions, but they absorb huge quantities of things from them, which is why, say, Tibetan Buddhism is riddled with deities and images from the pre-Buddhist religions. And in Christianity, even the very form of churches is taken over from pagan forms, the basilican shape of early Christian churches, hangings, incense, altars, carvings, sculptures, statues, icons in general.
还在于它们从这些旧信仰中吸收了大量的东西，这就是为什么，比如说，西藏佛教中充斥着前佛教宗教的神祇和形象。而在基督教中，甚至连教堂的形式本身都是从异教形式中接管过来的，比如早期基督教教堂的巴西利卡（basilica）式样、挂毯、熏香、祭坛、雕刻、雕塑、雕像、以及各种圣像。所有这一切都是对古老宗教的直接接管。我们甚至还没开始讨论民间风俗呢。在许多方面，发展成熟的基督教只是用一个基督教版本取代了旧宗教。你不再拥有许多女神和男神，而是拥有了许多不分性别的圣徒，他们庇护、照看的事情，正是古代异教女神和男神所做的事情。在古代异教中，季节性节日是重大的宗教活动。中世纪基督教也是如此。在古代异教中，牺牲——将食品供奉给神明——是核心的宗教仪式。在基督教中，这就是献上
All this is a direct takeover from the older religions. And we haven't even started upon the folk customs. And in many ways, developed Christianity just substitutes a Christian version for old religion. Instead of having many goddesses and gods, you have many saints of both sexes who patronize, look after the very things that pagan goddesses and gods did. In ancient paganism, seasonal festivals are the great religious occasions. The same is true of medieval Christianity. In ancient paganism, sacrifice, the offering up of foodstuffs to the deities, is the central religious rite. In Christianity, it's offering up the sacrifice of
弥撒的牺牲。所涉及的食品就是救世主的身体和血。事情就是这样一直延续下去的。这就是世界宗教成功的原因。罗纳德，我们之前讨论了可能从异教过渡到基督教欧洲的传统。关于其他一些稍微高雅一点的思想，即源自晚期古代异教的哲学思想，我们可以去到中东，来到一个耐人寻味的城市——如果在中世纪那里还有异教徒的话，他们不仅要在基督教的统治下存活，还要在伊斯兰教的统治下存活。伊斯兰教对偶像崇拜和异教观念的态度甚至比基督教更严厉、更强硬。
the mass. The foodstuffs concerned are the body and blood of the saviour. And it goes on and on and on like that. This is how world religions succeed. Ronald, we've talked about maybe the kind of traditions that pass from paganism through Christian Europe. On the topic of other slightly more highbrow ideas, philosophical ideas coming from late antique paganism, could we go to the Middle East and one intriguing city, which basically, if there were pagans there into the Middle Ages, they had to survive not only Christianity, but also Islam, which is kind of slightly more robust in its attitude towards ideas of idolatry and paganism, perhaps even more than Christianity.
这就是哈兰（Harran）城，也就是卡莱（Carrhae）城——古罗马历史爱好者会记得，这是克拉苏（Crassus）被帕提亚人击败的地方。这座城市哈兰，据说一直到公元10世纪、11世纪，都保存了一个庞大的异教徒社群，他们在那里既保留了异教崇拜的实践，也保留了某种古代传统、哲学上的异教传统，有人认为这些传统被穆斯林学者所采纳，随后这些传统又传入了西欧等等。你能稍微谈谈这个吗？
And that's the city of Haran, which was the city of Karai, which enthusiasts for Roman history will remember is the place where Crassus gets defeated by the Parthians. And this city, Haran, supposedly, right the way up into what, the 10th, 11th century, preserved a large community of pagans who kept there both the practice of pagan worship and also kind of ancient traditions, philosophical pagan traditions, which people have argued were adopted by Muslim scholars and then these traditions passed into Western Europe and so on. Could you just talk a bit about that?
如果你要在欧洲和近东寻找中世纪的异教徒，你会去两个地方。它们非常独立。一个是叙利亚的哈兰。正如你所提到的，它的废墟今天仍然在欧洲的东北部（译者注：原文如此，实际应为近东/叙利亚地区）。事实上，立陶宛存在的异教时间比哈兰还要长得多。哈兰是一座近东城市，后来成为该地区主要的阿拉伯首都。从政治上讲，它现在位于土耳其南部。在那里似乎存在着一个引人入胜的幸存异教徒社群，一直延续到11世纪或12世纪。他们遵循一种发达的异教形式，至少部分基于古希腊哲学。这东西是从哪里来的，我们并不确定。有很多想法。他们发生了什么，我们不得而知，只知道到了12世纪他们就消失了，到了13世纪这座城市就被废弃了。有些人认为哈兰的萨比教徒（Sabians）的思想——因为那是阿拉伯人给他们的宗教名称——影响了神秘主义伊斯兰教的一些分支，比如苏菲派。这可能是真的，
Yeah. If you're going to look for medieval pagans in Europe and the Near East, there are two places to which you go. They're very separate. One is Haran in Syria. As you've mentioned, its ruins are still there in the northeast of Europe. And indeed, Lithuania lasts a lot longer than Haran. Haran is a near eastern city, which becomes a major Arab capital for its area. It's now in the southern part of Turkey, politically. And it seems that there is a fascinating community of surviving pagans there until the 11th or 12th century, who follow a developed kind of paganism based at least partly on Greek philosophy. Where that came from, we aren't sure. There's lots of ideas. What happened to them, we don't know, except by the 12th century, they're gone, and by the 13th the city is deserted. And some have argued that the idea of the Sabians of Haram, because that's the denominational name the Arabs gave them, influenced some branches of mystical Islam, like the Sufis. That could be true,
它们有共同的元素，但也可能根本没有联系，只是一种巧合的相似。关于立陶宛，我们知道的要多得多，因为它持续的时间更长。立陶宛人是欧洲最后一批官方存在的异教徒。他们一直存活到14世纪末，很大程度上是因为当地没有人想让他们皈依，所有人都想征服他们。因此，大公们仍然保持着异教信仰。而大公们停止信仰异教，是因为通过一连串偶然的联姻，他们继承了波兰王国。为了得到波兰，你必须改信天主教。于是他们在一夜之间就改信了。因此，立陶宛慢慢变成了一个与波兰联合的基督教国家。但这是一种相当
there are elements in common, or there may actually be no connection, it may be a coincidental resemblance. Lithuania we know a lot more about because it goes on later. The Lithuanians are the last officially existing European pagans. They survive until the end of the 14th century, largely because nobody wants to convert them locally, they all want to conquer them. And so the Grand Dukes remain pagan. And the Grand Dukes stopped being pagan when owing to a fortuitous couple of marriage alliances, they inherit the Kingdom of Poland. And in order to get Poland, you've got to turn Catholic. And so they do overnight. And so Lithuania slowly turns into a Christian state united to Poland. But it's quite
激进、相当有生命力的中世纪异教，你在其他任何地方都找不到与之相似的存活案例。它击退了基督教的进攻。我们知道立陶宛人信仰什么吗？我们是否也知道为什么与其他欧洲异教相比，它会如此具有韧性？它之所以有韧性，正如刚才所说，纯粹是因为没有人真正想让他们皈依。他们不断在十字军东征中遭到攻击，对方只是为了寻找征服他们的借口，只不过异教徒足够顽强，能够相当成功地击退十字军东征，而且具有讽刺意味的是，当他们皈依时，反而吞并了十字军原本为之而来的部分土地。至于异教的类型，它拥有一个神祇万神殿。我已经阅读了所有翻译过来的史料——现在这已经成为可能，但它们非常混乱。
an aggressive, quite a viable medieval paganism of the sort you find surviving nowhere else. And it beats off Christian attacks. And do we know what the Lithuanians, what they believed? And do we also know why it's so resilient compared with other European paganisms? It's only resilient because nobody really wants to convert it, as said. They keep attacking it in crusades in order to have an excuse for conquering it, except the pagans are so tough they're able to beat off the crusades quite successfully, and indeed ironically to annex some of the lands the crusaders have come to when they convert. As for the type of paganism, it had a pantheon of deities. I've read all the sources in translation, which is now possible, and they're very confusing.
最早的史料显示，立陶宛人并没有占主导地位的女神或男神，只有范围广泛的地方崇拜，伴随着一条引人入胜但有些模糊的界线以及神圣的蛇——你在北欧其他地方往往找不到这些。但在皈依基督教大约200年后，立陶宛学者提出了这个为立陶宛人建立的、完善的普遍女神和男神万神殿，这有助于催生当今的新立陶宛异教，或者说复兴的异教。哦，对吧。立陶宛存在着一种新异教运动。
The earliest sources show no dominant goddesses or gods in general for Lithuanians, just a wide range of local cults with a fascinating but hazy line and sacred snakes. You tend not to find elsewhere in Northern Europe. But about 200 years after the conversion to Christianity, Lithuanian scholars come up with this established pantheon of universal goddesses and gods for Lithuanians, who've helped give birth to a new Lithuanian pagan religion at the present day, or a revived one. Oh, right. There's a neo-paganism in Lithuania.
你现在在欧洲各地都能找到现代异教徒，立陶宛当然也不例外。所以这些证据有点令人困惑。情况大致就是这样。这一切都是追溯性的。罗纳德，在我们中场休息之前，这是一个近乎疯狂的问题，因为这是一个极其宏大的话题。但既然我们在谈论异教，
You find modern pagans now all over Europe, certainly in Lithuania. So the evidence is a bit puzzling. And that's as much as it go. It's all retrospective. Ronald, just before we go to a break, and this is a kind of insane thing because it's a huge, huge topic. But if we're talking about paganism,
我们真该顺便提一下它们。哦，多米尼克需要一个避邪符来挡住咳嗽的恶魔。在15世纪，你发现了一次异教思想的复兴，
we should just mention them. Oh, Dominic needs an apotropaic charm to keep the demons of coughing at bay. In the 15th century, you get a revival, keep the demons of coughing at bay. In the 15th century, you get a revival supposedly of pagan ideas, both in Greece and in Italy. So in Greece at Mistras with this extraordinary figure,
据称在希腊和意大利都是如此。所以在希腊的米斯特拉斯（Mistras），有这样一位非凡的人物——
Pletho, who it has been thought revives the worship of the Greek gods. And in Renaissance Italy with Marsilio Ficino and people like him, who likewise are thought to have kind of revived the worship of the ancient gods, Platonism and so on. Can we call them pagans? Or are they operating still within a kind of Christian framework? I think they're operating still within a Christian framework, that they're trying to bring back pagan deities into it. They're trying to reintegrate them. And they're part of the same movement. Plato or Platon helps give birth to the Italian Renaissance because his ideas get in there. He goes on embassy, doesn't he, to Florence, I think. Yeah, he does. He actually goes there. And Greek scholars fleeing from the Turks bring in large
普莱索（Pletho），人们认为他复兴了对希腊诸神的崇拜。在文艺复兴时期的意大利，有马尔西利奥·费奇诺（Marsilio Ficino）及与其类似的人物，他们同样被认为复兴了对古代诸神、柏拉图主义等的崇拜。我们能称他们为异教徒吗？还是说他们仍然在某种基督教框架内运作？我认为他们仍然在某种基督教框架内运作，他们试图将异教神祇带回其中。他们试图重新整合这些神祇。他们是同一场运动的一部分。柏拉图主义（或柏拉图）帮助催生了意大利文艺复兴，因为他的思想渗入了那里。他曾作为特使去过佛罗伦萨，对吧？是的，他确实去过。实际上他亲自去了。从土耳其逃亡出来的希腊学者将大量
quantities of hugely important ancient Greek literature and Roman literature into Italy at just the right moment. So whether you call it a Byzantine or an Italian Renaissance, and it's both, 15th century scholars are trying very hard to recover the knowledge of the ancient world and then surf on it. But I think the language here is difficult because they're pagans in a sense that they are honoring pagan deities, but they're not in the sense they're trying to overturn or replace Christianity. They're trying to enrich it. Right. And particularly in the case of medieval Christian intellectuals, long before this, since the 12th century, when the Arabs produced the first great wave of recovered ancient Greek and Roman texts,
极其重要的古希腊文学和罗马文学带入了意大利，时机恰到好处。所以，无论你称之为拜占庭文艺复兴还是意大利文艺复兴（其实两者兼而有之），15世纪的学者都在非常努力地恢复对古代世界的知识并借此乘风破浪。但我认为这里的语言很难界定，因为他们在某种意义上是异教徒，因为他们尊崇异教神祇；但从他们并非试图推翻或取代基督教的意义上讲，他们又不是异教徒。他们是在试图丰富基督教。没错。特别是中世纪的基督教知识分子，在此之前很久，自12世纪以来——当时阿拉伯人掀起了第一波恢复古希腊和古罗马文本的高潮——
there's been this desire to put back the Olympian deities as rulers of planets. In other words, it's recognized that heavenly bodies have an influence on the earth, like the moon being linked to the tides. And the basis of astrology is the idea that the other heavenly bodies influence the world and so human life. And so if you reinstate those ancient deities, Greek and Roman, that are linked to planets as servants of the almighty God who control things on earth, you're giving them a huge amount of refreshed agency while keeping them on board as part of the Christian team. Right. Okay. That's absolutely brilliant. I think we should go for a break now. And when we come back, if we could go as far back in time as we can, say, let's look at Britain, let's focus in
人们就一直有一种愿望，想要把奥林匹斯诸神作为行星的统治者重新请回来。换句话说，人们认识到天体对地球有影响，就像月亮与潮汐相连一样。占星术的基础就是这样一种理念：其他天体影响着世界，进而影响着人类的生活。因此，如果你把那些与行星相连的古希腊罗马神祇作为全能上帝的仆人重新恢复起来，由他们来控制地球上的事物，你就是在赋予他们大量重新焕发活力的代理权，同时又让他们作为基督教团队的一部分留在船上。没错。好的。这绝对太精彩了。我想我们现在应该去休息一下。等我们回来时，如果我们能尽可能把时间往前推，比如，让我们看看英国，把焦点集中在
on paganism in Britain. What can we know about pre-Christian paganism in Britain? How far back can we push it? So we will see you in a few minutes. all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are approaching the final lap of our canter around the course of paganism with Professor Ronald Hutton from the University of Bristol. Ronald, let's cut right to the chase, something you've written about. We had a question from a listener called Robbie Rippamonte, and he says, can we know anything for certain about the Druids? Only that they existed.
英国的异教上。关于前基督教时期的英国异教，我们能知道些什么？我们能把它推溯到多远以前？我们几分钟后见。各项工作都在顺利进行。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果您想收听无广告音频、加更节目并提前获得现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的余烬》。我们正在进行围绕异教之旅的最后一圈冲刺，与我们同行的有来自布里斯托尔大学的罗纳德·赫顿教授。罗纳德，让我们直奔主题，谈谈你曾写过的一些内容。我们有一位名叫罗比·里帕蒙蒂（Robbie Rippamonte）的听众提问说，关于德鲁伊（Druids），我们能确切知道些什么吗？只有一件事：他们确实存在过。
They were the experts in religion, spirituality, religious ritual in northwestern Europe at the dawn of history. And that's it. which marks them off. But we have not a single word, as far as we know, of writing left by the Druids themselves describing what they did. And there's not a single artifact among the hundreds of thousands that have been recovered from the pre-Roman European Iron Age, which can definitely be linked to them. What we have instead are a small number of rather brief descriptions of them by Greek and Roman writers, and all of them are suspect for different reasons. Some are deeply admiring, but they may have been the work of dewy-eyed intellectuals living thousands of miles away who'd never met a druid. And rather more of them are deeply hostile, representing Druids as bloodthirsty barbarian priests dyed to the elbows in human gore.
在历史的拂晓时期，他们是西北欧的宗教、灵性和宗教仪式专家。仅此而已。这使他们显得与众不同。但据我们所知，德鲁伊自己留下的文字记录中没有留下哪怕一个字来描述他们所做的事情。在从前罗马时期的欧洲铁器中出土的成千上万件文物中，没有一件能够明确与他们联系起来。相反，我们拥有的只是一些希腊和罗马作家对他们相当简短的描述，而且由于种种原因，所有这些描述都值得怀疑。有些描述充满了崇拜，但它们可能是那些从未见过德鲁伊、生活在数千英里之外、戴着有色眼镜的知识分子的产物。而更多的描述则是极具敌意的，把德鲁伊描绘成嗜血的蛮族祭司，双肘沾满了人类的鲜血。
So this is where Wiccan men come from, isn't it? Yeah, they could have been the work of authors justifying the Roman conquest and expropriation of the lands held by Druids, especially as Druids featured in some narratives as resistance leaders to the Romans. So they're all suspect. There's a bit more body of evidence for those who notice it in the medieval Irish texts. Ireland matters because it's a society where actually had Druids. So you have descriptions of Druids by the natives themselves. Unfortunately, they're all from centuries after the conversion to Christianity. And we've no idea how good the information of the authors were. They could be making it up again. So in no case can we condemn a single ancient or medieval image of an ancient Druid as inauthentic. But in no case can we accept one as fully reliable that's why they're great to think with and so the idea that merlin was a druid i think merlin's a very bad fit for
所以这就是威卡教男性的来源，对吧？是的，它们也可能是某些作者为了证明罗马征服和剥夺德鲁伊所拥有的土地是正义的而炮制的作品，特别是德鲁伊在某些叙事中被描绘成对抗罗马人的抵抗领袖。所以这些记载都值得怀疑。对于那些注意到这一点的人来说，中世纪爱尔兰文本中提供了更多实质性的证据。爱尔兰之所以重要，是因为它是一个确实存在过德鲁伊的社会。因此，那里保留了当地人对德鲁伊的描述。不幸的是，这些描述都来自基督教化之后的几个世纪。我们完全不知道这些作者的信息有多可靠。他们也可能是凭空捏造的。因此，在任何情况下，我们都不能断定某一个关于古代德鲁伊的古代或中世纪图像是绝对不真实的；但同样地，也没有哪个图像能被完全接受为绝对可靠。这就是为什么他们非常适合用来进行思考。所以，认为梅林是个德鲁伊的观点……我认为梅林很不符合
a druid uh for a start he isn't really human he is the offspring of a nun and a demon and it's having 50% demon blood that gives him his magical powers. And he's also the advisor to a king who, in all his representations from the earliest until the late 20th century, is a devout Christian. Yeah. Okay. All right. Well, we'll finish with the Druids then. But in the context of Roman Britainain you might have this idea that um you know we have the druids we don't really think about them then the romans come they write so therefore we must know loads about uh what is going on in roman britain but in your your wonderful book pagan britain um you you describe um a group of elderly women who were found at Kimmeridge in Dorset, who'd had their heads chopped off, their lower jaws removed, put by their feet, and each one had been provided with a spindle. So what's going on there?
德鲁伊的形象。首先，他并不是真正的人类，他是修女和恶魔的后代，正是拥有50%的恶魔血统才赋予了他魔法力量。而且他还是一个国王的谋士，而这位国王在从最早一直到20世纪末的所有形象中，都是一个虔诚的基督徒。是的。好吧。好吧，我们就以德鲁伊作为这个话题的结束。但在罗马不列颠的背景下，你可能会有这样一种想法：你知道的，我们有德鲁伊，我们其实不太去想他们，然后罗马人来了，他们留下了文字记录，所以我们一定对罗马不列颠发生的事情了如指掌。但在你那本精彩的著作《异教不列颠》（Pagan Britain）中，你描述了
Anybody's guess. Clearly, there's a specific range of options. They're wise women who are being honoured after death with a particular right. And indeed, removing their lower jaw could be to allow them to speak even more freely to their descendants or to those yet living. Or they could be people suspected of witchcraft who've had their jaws removed so they can no longer utter curses and imprecations they've actually been put to death uh and the spindle is a symbol of those who weave spells to label them as bad now these are extreme opposite cases and you can find anything on the spectrum between uh what i said before was we know an awful lot, an agreeable lot about Greek and Roman religion.
在多塞特郡的基梅雷奇（Kimmeridge）发现的一组老年女性骨骸，她们的头颅被砍掉，下颌骨被移除并放在脚边，每个人身边都配有一个纺锤。那里的情况是怎么回事？
We don't know a lot about Romano-British religion in particular. The Romano-British did not produce books that have survived to the present day. And they produced a large number of inscriptions, but they tend to be brief and enigmatic. So in Warwickshire at Waspeton, if you find a slab of stone, which had a fire Stag's antlers put on it, and then the word Feliciter for luck engraved on it, what's going on there? It's anybody's guess. I mean, I've always found the weirdness of, say, images of gods that people have no idea what they are, actually much more kind of haunting than the attempts to reproduce, I don't know, kind of Mediterranean
谁也说不准。显然，这里有一系列可能的选项。她们可能是受人尊敬的智者女性，在死后通过某种特殊的仪式获得荣誉。事实上，移除她们的下颌骨可能是为了让她们能够更加自由地与后代或在世的人对话。或者，她们可能是被怀疑犯有巫术的人，移除下颌骨是为了让她们无法再吐出诅咒和恶毒的话语——她们实际上被处死了，而纺锤则是用来织法术的人的象征，用来给她们贴上坏人的标签。这些是极端的对立情况，你可以在我刚才说的两极之间找到光谱上的任何东西。正如我之前所说，我们对希腊和罗马宗教了解得非常多，甚至多得惊人。但我们对罗马-不列颠宗教的了解其实并不多。罗马-不列颠人并没有留下流传至今的书籍。他们虽然留下了大量的铭文，但往往都简短而神秘。所以在沃里克郡的沃斯佩顿（Waspeton），如果你发现一块刻有火红的鹿角、并且还雕刻着表示“幸运”的拉丁单词“Feliciter”的石板，那到底是怎么回事？
style classical statuary. So I always remember the coccolati, the hooded ones, and they're shown on a frieze at Halstead's Fort on Hadrian's Wall. And I think I'm right right we have no idea really who they are what they represent or anything and I've always found them kind of more tantalizing for that reason. I agree and they're great to work imaginatively with at the present day for that reason it's not just the hooded spirits the Ghani Kukul, it's whole categories of deity, like the Matres or Matroni, the mother goddesses, who are three portly ladies sitting in a row with goodies, usually fruit, bread, on their laps. And they're clearly givers of bounty, but we have no backstory for them. We have no mythology. They're incredibly popular with soldiers, maybe because soldiers need luck,
谁也说不准。我的意思是，我一直觉得那些人们根本不知道代表什么的诡异神明形象，实际上比那些试图模仿地中海风格古典雕塑的尝试更让人难以忘怀。所以我总是想起那些“戴帽子的神明”（Coccolati，意为披斗篷者），他们在哈德良长城的豪斯泰兹堡（Houseesteads Fort）的一处雕带上被描绘出来。如果我没记错的话，我们其实并不知道他们究竟是谁，代表着什么，或者任何其他信息。正因如此，我一直觉得他们有一种更引人入胜的魅力。我非常赞同，正是因为这个原因，他们在今天的想象力创作中非常出色。不仅是戴帽子的精灵，还有整个神明类别，比如“三母神”（Matres或Matroni），她们是三个端坐在长凳上、膝头放着供品（通常是水果、面包）的丰满女士。她们显然是慷慨的施赠者，但我们没有关于她们的任何背景故事。我们没有她们的神话。她们在士兵中极其受欢迎，也许是因为士兵需要运气，
or soldiers get hungry, or soldiers just miss their mums. They come from probably the modern Rhineland or the Rhineland and spread out from there. But why or how, we've no idea. So once you're north of the Alps, you're in pretty mystifying territory, even under Rome. So if we know so little about Romano-British religion, and indeed the folk religion, if you like, of Roman soldiers on the frontiers and so on, what can we say about the world before the Romans came? So, you know, when Julius Caesar and then later Claudius, when they pitch up in Britain, what are the people worshipping? Or do we just not know at all? We have a very dimly lit view of religion in Britain at that moment, because the Romans consecrate and adopt many of the deities and the shrines of the natives. So we have the names and the imagined appearances of a lot of pre-Roman goddesses and gods that survive into Roman Britain. And we can reconstruct something
或者士兵容易饿，或者士兵只是想念妈妈。她们可能起源于现代的莱茵兰地区，并从那里传播开来。但究竟为什么以及如何传播的，我们一无所知。所以，一旦你到了阿尔卑斯山以北，你就进入了一个相当神秘的领域，即使在罗马统治下也是如此。因此，如果我们对罗马-不列颠宗教知之甚少，对边境罗马士兵等群体的民间宗教也所知甚少，那么对于罗马人到来之前的世界，我们又能说些什么呢？所以，当尤利乌斯·凯撒后来克劳狄来到不列颠时，当地人在崇拜什么？还是说我们根本一无所知？对于那一刻不列颠的宗教，我们的视野非常昏暗，因为罗马人将当地人的许多神明和神殿奉为神圣并加以吸收。所以我们掌握了许多前罗马时期的女神和男神的名称以及想象中的外貌，这些一直延续到了罗马不列颠时期。我们可以重建
of the layout and the purpose of particular Iron Age shrines, because they're turned into Roman temples. But once you go back more than, say, 100 years before the Romans arrived, the lights just go out. And it's not just religion. It's anything that requires knowing what people are thinking. So we have, after about half a millennium, no real idea of society. We have no idea of gender relations. We have no idea of gender relations. We have no idea of political structures. And by the time you go back 2,000 years, you could be looking at matriarchy, patriarchy,
特定铁器时代神殿的布局和用途，因为它们后来变成了罗马神庙。但一旦你往回追溯到罗马人到来之前超过100年的时间，灯光就直接熄灭了。不仅宗教如此，任何需要了解人们想法的事物都是如此。所以在经历了大约半个世纪（译者注：原文为half a millennium，即半个千年纪/五百年）之后，我们对当时的社会实际上毫无所知。我们对性别关系一无所知。我们对政治结构一无所知。当你把时间推回到2000年前时，你看到的可能是母权制，也可能是父权制，
aristocracy, monarchy, petty chieftains, democracy, oligarchy, all the archies and ologies of actual service. Now, it doesn't mean we know nothing about them. Because of what technology can give us, we know more and more about their ethnicity, their diet, their technology, their living spaces, their handicrafts. It's anything that involves getting into the human mind that's still a closed world. And presumably, I mean, so Britain is famous for its prehistoric monuments and that they're stamped across the country, standing stones, barrows, great hills, in the case of Silbury Hill. I guess the temptation is to see them all as a kind of indistinguishable flux. But presumably, the different style of these monuments presumably must reflect different attitudes
贵族、君主制、小首领、民主制、寡头制，实际应用中的各种政体。现在，这并不意味着我们对它们一无所知。由于技术能提供给我们的信息，我们对它们的种族、饮食、技术、居住空间以及手工艺了解得越来越多。任何涉及人类心灵且仍属封闭世界的事物都是如此。据我所知，英国以其史前纪念碑而闻名，它们遍布全国各地——立石、古坟、巨大的山丘，例如西尔伯里山。我想人们很容易把它们看作是一种分不清区别的流动体。但据推测，这些纪念碑的不同风格必定反映了不同的态度
to the supernatural, to humanity's relationship to the cosmos. And they must be expression of kind of evolutions in that understanding that we simply can't get a handle on? We can't, but we can say that quite big things are going on in terms of religious change. It's intermittent. It happens about once every one and a half thousand years, but it's quite dramatic. So there's really not much tradition of monument building apart from posts in Britain until the Neolithic arrives. That's the package of farming and making polished axes and pottery. But once that arrives, the British suddenly go monument mad for two millennia and for about a thousand years their main monuments are closed chambers of big stones or big timbers sealed in by mounds and often containing the human dead the bones of which
对超自然现象，对人类与宇宙关系的理解。它们必然是这种理解中某种演变的表达，而这是我们根本无法把握的？我们无法把握，但我们可以说，在宗教变革方面正在发生相当重大的事情。它是间歇性的。大约每千五百年发生一次，但相当戏剧化。因此，在英国新石器时代到来之前，除了柱子之外，实际上没有多少建造纪念碑的传统。那是一套包括农耕、制作抛光石斧和陶器的综合体系。但一旦这些到来，英国人突然在两个千纪里疯狂地建造纪念碑，在大约一千年里，他们的主要纪念碑是由大石头或大木头组成的封闭墓室，外面封上封土堆，里面通常包含人类死者的骨骼
are taken out and worked with so this is a religion which looks as if it's mediated at least partly through the dead. And then around 3000 BCE, BC, 5000 years ago, these monuments are abandoned. In fact, they're often blocked up to stop access. And instead, the British Isles go mad about round shapes. The dead are increasingly interred in round mounds and they're given goods as personal possessions and they're sealed in, they're not contacted physically anymore. And people gather to worship not at these great tomb shrines but in spaces defined by circular barriers, banks of earth, circles of standing stones, or circles of big wooden posts. Now, this is a massive conceptual change. It requires a religious reformation.
这些骨骼被取出并进行加工，所以这似乎是一种至少部分通过死者进行中介的宗教。然后在大约公元前3000年，也就是5000年前，这些纪念碑被废弃了。事实上，它们经常被封堵以阻止人们进入。取而代之的是，不列颠群岛对圆形建筑疯狂着迷。死者越来越多地被安葬在圆形的坟丘中，并被赋予个人财物作为陪葬品，他们被封存在里面，不再与生者进行身体上的接触。人们聚集在一起崇拜，不是在这些伟大的陵墓圣地，而是在由圆形屏障、土堤、立石圈或巨大木柱圈所界定的空间里。现在，这是一个巨大的概念转变。它需要一场宗教改革。
But what the story is, is really for novelists or the poet. A pre-historian can't go there. And you mentioned that human remains. So there are kind of, I mean, kind of all kinds of strange, like, like they, I think in Kent, they would smoke their grandfathers and grandmothers and hang them from the roof, which presumably must be expressive of some, I mean, obviously dead. It must be expressive of, of kind of something that we just can't. It's like we've got the hardware, but not the software. Yes, that's a very good parallel. And it's the case throughout prehistory.
但故事的真相究竟如何，其实是留给小说家或诗人的。史前史研究者无法涉足。你刚才提到了人类遗骸。所以有一种，我的意思是，各种各样奇怪的现象，比如，我认为在肯特郡，他们会把祖父祖母的遗体熏制然后挂在屋顶上，这想必表达了某种，我的意思是，很显然是针对死者的。它一定表达了某种我们根本无法理解的东西。这就像我们拥有了硬件，却没有软件。是的，这是一个非常好的比喻。而且整个史前时期都是如此。
Again, people react to prehistory with their guts, with their instincts. And really the classic division for hundreds of years is between those who really see humanity as essentially decent and those who really see it as essentially depraved. And so people who see humanity as essentially decent will find a set of human skulls and long bones interred around an Iron Age enclosure and say this is revering the ancestors these are great warriors or wise people whose mortal remains were revered like saints relics after their death often for a long time and then interred as saints remains are interred in churches in the enclosures to sanctify them and those who have the opposite reaction will say these are clearly trophies taken in war or the remains of human sacrifices who are put on display to terrify everybody else or to make people feel good that they can trash marginal people in their
同样，人们凭直觉和本能对史前史做出反应。数百年来，最经典的划分实际上在于那些真正认为人类本质上是正派的人，以及那些真正认为人类本质上是堕落的人。因此，那些认为人类本质上正派的人会发现一组人类头骨和长骨被安葬在一个铁器时代围场的周围，并说这是在尊崇祖先，这些是伟大的勇士或智者，他们的凡躯死后像圣徒遗物一样受到长期尊崇，然后像圣徒遗物一样被安葬在围场内的教堂里以使其神圣化；而那些有相反反应的人则会说，这些显然是在战争中夺取的战利品，或者是活人献祭的遗骸，被拿出来展览以吓唬其他人，或者让人觉得他们可以贬低社会边缘人群
society or tribal enemies and then when everybody's got bored with them and have decapitated a few new people, they chuck them into pits to get rid of them. Now, these are not compatible visions. They depend utterly upon instinctually opposed views of humans, and we'll always have them. Yeah, yeah. So pushing right the way back, that brilliantly brings us to one of the most famous sites in prehistoric Britain, which is Gough's Cave in Cheddar Gorge. So we're talking, what, 1300, 1200 BC. And there, human remains have been found, which exactly exemplify what you're talking about. So there are skulls that have been turned into kind of drinking cups. And people say, is this respect for an elder or something? Or is it evidence for cannibalism?
或是部落敌人，当所有人都对他们感到厌烦并斩首了几个新的人之后，就把他们扔进坑里除掉。现在，这些观点是无法调和的。它们完全依赖于对人类截然对立的直觉看法，而且我们将永远持有这种分歧。是的，是的。所以追溯到底，这非常出色地把我们带到了史前不列颠最著名的遗址之一，即切达峡谷的戈夫洞穴。我们讨论的是，公元前1300年还是1200年？在那里，人们发现了人类遗骸，这恰好完美地体现了你刚才所说的情况。有些头骨被变成了某种饮酒器皿。人们会问，这是对长者的尊重还是某种东西？或者这是同类相食的证据？
And is there any sense of a consensus on that? No. It depends by now, because we're a multicultural society based on individuals, not even on the prevailing mood of the time or social norms, but on whims of individual archaeologists. And they tend to disagree. What we do about this, I don't know. I have a strong view on one side of the debate uh because really we do have options and the big options are to celebrate our ignorance and to say that anybody's view is as good as anybody else's so let's have as many views as possible because the law of average dictates the more you have the more chance there is that somebody will be right but you'll never know which one you'll never know
对于这一点，有什么共识吗？没有。现在已经没有了，因为我们是一个建立在个人基础上的多元文化社会，甚至不取决于当时的普遍情绪或社会规范，而是取决于个别考古学家的奇思妙想。而且他们往往意见不一。对此我们该怎么办，我不知道。在这个争论的一方，我有强烈的看法，呃，因为实际上我们有选择，而重大的选择是庆祝我们的无知，并说任何人的观点都和别人的观点一样好，所以让我们拥有尽可能多的观点，因为平均法则决定了你拥有的观点越多，某个人正确的几率就越大，但你永远不会知道究竟是谁，你永远不会知道
though who who but at least we're producing the range of possibilities uh but there's still a strong tradition which is uh ingrained in western scholarship of the gladiatorial approach that academics heatedly espouse. Duke it out. And then do battle with each other. The public looks on and decides the victor or the victor will emerge. And that becomes the orthodoxy until another strong contender emerges and kills off the reigning theory. I actually loathe that, A, because I'm a nice guy, but also because it seems to me rather intellectually dishonest.
究竟是谁——但至少我们正在展现各种可能性，呃，不过在西方学术界仍然根深蒂固着一种强烈的传统，那就是角斗士式的approach，即学者们激烈争论。放手一搏。然后彼此交战。公众在一旁观看并决定胜者，或者胜者会脱颖而出。这就成了正统，直到另一个强有力的竞争者出现并杀死现有的理论。我其实很讨厌这种做法，A，因为我是个好人，但也因为它对我来说似乎在智力上有些不够诚实。
I mean, we are a very competitive society. One of our major popular forms of entertainment is the competition, whether it's Big Brother, Strictly, the show for which there can only be one or one pair of winners. And to me, it's a lousy attitude to scholarship. Now, I was going to say, can we push it back even further? I mean, lots of people will want to ask this question.
我的意思是，我们是一个极具竞争性的社会。我们最主要的流行娱乐形式之一就是比赛，无论是《老大哥》、《严格来舞》还是只能产生一个或一对赢家的节目。对我来说，这是对待学术的一种糟糕态度。刚才我正要说，我们能把它推得更远吗？我的意思是，很多人都会想问这个问题。
It's a subject very dear to Tom's heart. Stonehenge. I mean, that's the site that has generated more theories than any other and and i guess it you'd say the same about stonehenge right that there was literally nothing at all or very little that we can say with any certainty at all about what people were doing there why they built it and what it meant yeah correct. We're now brilliant at knowing exactly when it was put up, how it was put up, and by whom it was put up, but not why it was put up. And we've made some advances over the last half millennium. We know that it belongs to the British New Stone Age, that it wasn't built by the Wizard Merlin, King Arthur,
这是汤姆非常关心的主题。巨石阵。我的意思是，这个遗址产生的理论比任何其他遗址都要多，我想你对巨石阵也会这么说，对吧？那就是关于人们在那里做什么、他们为什么建造它以及它意味着什么，我们实际上根本没有任何或者极少有能够确凿说出的东西。是的，完全正确。我们现在非常擅长准确了解它是何时建造的、如何建造的以及由谁建造的，但却不知道为什么要建造它。在过去半个千纪里，我们取得了一些进展。我们知道它属于不列颠新石器时代，它不是由梅林魔法师、亚瑟王建造的
the Anglo-Saxons, the Vikings or the Romans which were all theories up for grabs until the 18th century. So we've made progress but as for what went on there really it's again up to people's instincts where whether you're visualising a group of wise women clad in white robes deeply in touch with the secrets of nature and the movements of heavens or a male equivalent or mixed sex or you're visualising a bunch of savages
盎格鲁-撒克逊人、维京人或罗马人，这些都是直到18世纪还在争论的理论。所以我们取得了进展，但至于那里究竟发生了什么，这其实再次取决于人们的直觉：你想象的是一群身穿白袍、深刻感悟自然秘密和天体运行的智者女性，还是一个男性版本的群体，或者是男女混合，又或者你想象的是一群野人
covered in paint whooping round the place with stone tomahawks and butchering human victims, because they're both equally credible. I guess what I would say is that one thing we can know is that it clearly had some sacral, some spiritual, some kind of holy significance. And it wasn't just Stonehenge, it was the landscape around it as well. And that the fact that this has survived is itself, it gives us a sense of communion with the people who made it, even if we have no idea why they were doing it. And that that in thousands of years on is something I would say precious, and I would go so far as to say sacred.
浑身涂满颜料，挥舞着石战斧在那个地方呼喊，并屠杀人类祭品，因为这两种说法都同样可信。我想我要说的是，我们可以确定的一点是，它显然具有某种神圣的、精神上的、某种神圣的意义。而且不仅仅是巨石阵，它周围的景观也是如此。它能够保存至今这一事实本身，就带给我们一种与建造它的人进行心灵交流的感觉，尽管我们根本不知道他们为什么要这样做。而且在数千年后的今天，我认为这是极其宝贵的东西，我甚至可以说它是神圣的。
Yes, and it fits in exactly with my celebration of our prehistory and that should be honoured so we have a growing body of resources for an increasingly unfettered imagination i think that's a really healthy place to be in a multicultural multi-faith society and it should definitely be honoured by not building a large tunnel through the landscape. I knew you were going to bring that up. Yeah, I was just going to bring it up. Ronald, we've been whistling back through time. Could we end by looking at what I think, certainly in your book, you describe as the earliest
是的，这完全符合我对我们史前史的礼赞，这应该受到尊重。因此，我们为日益不受束缚的想象力提供了越来越多的资源，我认为在一个多元文化、多信仰的社会里，这是一个非常健康的处境，并且绝对应该通过不在风景区修建一条大型隧道来予以尊重。我知道你要提这个。是的，我正要提。罗纳德，我们刚才像乘着微风一样回溯了时间。我们能否以探讨我认为、当然在你的书中你所描述的最早的
evidence for paganism, I suppose for any kind of spiritual dimension within Britain, which is the Red Lady of Paveland, as it was called. But she wasn't a lady, was she? So Paveland is on the Gower Peninsula. What is the Red Lady? And how old is he or she? It's a he. He's a young man, five foot seven, five foot eight, who was buried around 34,000 years ago, which is certainly the oldest ceremonial human burial in this part of the world, northwest Europe, and possibly the oldest in Europe. And by ceremonial, he was interred on the floor of a cave, which was then in a very striking golden cliff, it's still golden, overlooking a broad plain stretching out to France, as France now is. And he was dressed in a two-piece garment, which was dyed bright red.
证据来结束这次访谈——英国境内关于萨满教、或者说任何精神层面的最早证据，也就是所谓的帕夫兰的红夫人。但她并不是一位女士，对吧？所以帕夫兰位于高尔半岛。红夫人究竟是什么？他或她有多大年纪？这是一个男性。他是一个年轻男子，身高五尺七到五尺八，大约在34,000年前下葬，这无疑是世界这一地区（西北欧）最古老的仪式性人类墓葬，也可能是欧洲最古老的墓葬。之所以称之为仪式性，是因为他被安葬在一个洞穴的地板上，那个洞穴当时位于一个非常醒目的金色悬崖上，现在依然是金色的，俯瞰着一片一直延伸到法国（即现在的法国）的广阔平原。他身穿一套染成鲜红色的两件套服装。
So this is not a hunting outfit. It's a ceremonial garment and seems to be associated with a mammoth skull, certainly associated with broken ivory objects, conical and carefully made in segments that look like wands. They have no practical use. They are ceremonial wands or septons that have been ritually broken and placed over his body. Now, by anybody's rendering, this is heavy duty ritual. It's a very careful burial. His head was missing, which may have been due to later disturbance or may have been related to the nature of his death. But he's somebody given great honour. And the attire is that of somebody with a high ceremonial function. So this looks like we can quibble over the term endlessly.
所以这不是一套狩猎服装。这是一套礼服，似乎与一个猛犸象头骨有关，而且肯定与破碎的象牙制品有关——这些象牙制品呈圆锥形，经过精心分段制作，看起来像魔杖。它们没有任何实际用途。它们是经过仪式性折断并放置在他身体上的礼杖或权杖。无论按谁的理解，这都是高级别的仪式。这是一场非常仔细的葬礼。他的头部不见了，这可能是由于后来的扰动造成的，也可能与他死亡的性质有关。但他是一个受到极高荣誉的人。这套装束属于具有高级宗教职责的人。所以看起来我们可以对这个词无休止地争论不解。
As we see it, the birth of British religion. And on that bombshell, I can't thank you enough. It's been an absolute tour de force. Well, I was asked really, really well-informed, intelligent questions, both by the two, especially by the two of you, but also by your followers. I think that one of the reasons why the two of you like me is that I'm a heavyweight academic who actually writes like a pop historian, not just in going for purple passages, but for covering an embarrassingly wide range of interests.
正如我们所看到的，这是英国宗教的诞生。伴随着这个重磅消息，我对你感激不尽。这绝对是一场精彩绝伦的演讲。嗯，我被问到了非常、非常有见地、聪明的问题，不仅是你们两个，尤其是你们两个，还有你们的听众。我想你们俩喜欢我的原因之一，是因为我是一个重量级的学者，但写起文章来却像一个通俗历史作家，不仅追求华丽的辞藻，而且涉及令人尴尬的广泛兴趣范围。
Everything you write on this subject is so fascinating. I particularly recommend The Statues of the Sun as we go into winter, if you want to keep your spirits up, all kinds of festive paganism there. And your most recent book, The Making of Cromwell, absolutely superb book. And you've talked, I think, at the beginning
你在这个主题上写的一切都如此迷人。随着冬天的来临，如果你想保持振奋的心情，我特别推荐《太阳的雕像》，那里有各种各样的节日异教习俗。还有你最近的书，《克伦威尔的塑造》，绝对是一本极佳的书。而且你谈到了，我想是在昨天节目的开头
of yesterday's episode about your love of the english countryside and one of the really striking things about the making cromwell is it's brilliant not only on cromwell but on the seasons and the flowers and the plants and the landscape of england it's kind of very unexpected in a book about um about the civil war so thank you so much for coming on thank you dominic we are back aren are back, aren't we, on the 4th of November with a 5th of November special. Oh, with a preview of the Gunpowder Plot.
关于你对英格兰乡村的热爱，而《克伦威尔的塑造》中最令人印象深刻的事情之一就是，它不仅在克伦威尔的描写上十分精彩，而且在英格兰的季节、花卉、植物和风景方面也极其出色。在一本关于内战的书里，这显得非常出人意料。所以非常感谢你来参加节目。谢谢你，多米尼克。我们还要回来，对吧？在11月4日，会有一个11月5日的特辑。哦，还有对火药阴谋的预览。
Yes. So, which is, of course, one of the few, I guess, kind of modern British festivities, English festivities. Yes.
是的。所以，这当然是少数几个，我想是现代英国节日、英格兰节日之一。是的。
Something about which Ronald has also written. Fascinatingly. And we may be name-checking in that episode. I think we will. I think we will. Okay.
罗纳德也曾对此进行过书写。非常迷人。我们可能会在那期节目中提及这个名字。我想我们会提及的。我想会的。好的。
Thanks ever so much. All right. Thank you, everybody. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
非常感谢。好的。谢谢大家，再见。再见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想要收听独家节目、提前点播、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。